CECILIA ROUSE: Welcome back.
I hope you had a
wonderful summer
and that you're relaxed,
and refreshed, and ready
for a fabulous academic year.
FLORENT MASSE: Welcome to
Princeton, great class of 2018,
and welcome back to
all returning students.
We look forward to having you
in language and arts classes
here at Princeton.
PACE CENTER FOR
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT:
Welcome to Princeton where you
can serve, lead, and inspire
with us.
See you in September.
MOLLIE MARCOUX: Welcome
back Princetonians.
It's going to be
an awesome year.
BOB SURACE: We hope to see you
at all of our athletic events.
Best wishes on a great start. Go tigers.
MOLLIE MARCOUX: Go tigers.
CAMPUS DINING:
Welcome class of 2018.
Come to your great
culinary experience
here at Princeton University.
MICHAEL CHANG: Welcome back
to Princeton, everyone.
I hope you guys enjoy
your fall semester
while I'm abroad
studying in England.
DAVIS INTERNATIONAL CENTER:
The Davis International Center
welcomes back to campus all
of our international students
and scholars from
around the world.
LEWIS CENTER FOR
THE ARTS: Welcome
to the Lewis Center
for the Arts.
WHITMAN COLLEGE
OFFICE: Welcome back to the residential colleges.
MARISA SANDERS: Hey everyone.
Welcome back to Princeton.
I hope you had a great
summer, and here's
to an awesome year of research.
THE GRADUATE SCHOOL: The
graduate school welcomes you.
OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABILITY: Welcome,
from the office
of sustainability.
NANA ABOAGYE: Welcome
back to campus.
ADEDOYIN TERIBA:
And we want to wish
you a productive and
successful academic session.
ANNEMARIE LUIJENDIJK:
Welcome to Princeton.
I hope to see you
in class this year.
LIBRARIAN: From the
Princeton University Library,
welcome to the class of 2018
and to returning students.
MAN 1 FROM SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AND APPLIED
SCIENCE: On behalf of the School
of Engineering and Applied
Science, welcome to all
new and returning students.
WOMAN FROM SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AND APPLIED SCIENCE:
And a special welcome to
the new graduate students.
MAN 2 FROM SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AND APPLIED SCIENCE:
And a special welcome
to the class of 2018.
CYNTHIA CHERREY: To all
of our students, welcome.
And to our new graduate students
and to the great class of 2018,
we are so glad that
you are joining us.
LEE HENSLEY: Welcome back,
and have a good year.
DEPARTMENT OF MATHEMATICS:
Welcome to the math department.
SARAH YERIMA: I'm really
happy that classes
are starting again.
I can't wait for my senior year.
Shoutout to all of the seniors.
Get ready for our last
year at Princeton.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: I am so
glad everyone's back.
Everyone's glad that
everyone's back.
You just walk out on the campus.
So welcome, welcome.
Seriously, welcome back.
EDUARDO CADAVA:
Welcome to New Jersey.
You're about to embark
on four years that
are certain to be among the
most important and exciting
in your lives, and
I want to offer you
my very best wishes
for your new journey.